[Music]
welcome back to CBS morning's America's
latest mass shooting as you know took
place inside a school full of young
children three nine-year-old students
just sit with that for just a second
nine-year-old students and three adults
were killed at the Covenant School in
Nashville Tennessee surveillance video
shows a moment that this shooter entered
the school we have to warn you you've
seen it it's extremely disturbing you
can see the shooter Who police say was a
former student breaking a glass door
with gunfire police say this attacker
was heavily armed and this attack was
carefully planned we're joined Now by
Nashville's police chief his name is
John Drake
good to see you Chief Drake I'm so sorry
it's under these circumstances my heart
is so heavy I'm so sad so angry and mad
I can not imagine how you were feeling
this morning I've seen interviews with
you where you say that you think the
motive here was resentment what do you
mean by resentment what does that mean
resentment about what
so so the investigation is still ongoing
into this whole incident but what
detectives have said so far is there
there's possibly some resentment for
having to go to that school there's a
connection with that family right now I
can't go deeply into that because it's
unconfirmed but that's uh that's really
where that came from
what makes you say the attack was
carefully planned
so that we have a Manifesto we have a
booklet that shows uh the uh exactly
what she had planned to do we have maps
that showed the entry point into the
school uh the weapons that was going to
be used uh the clothing that she was
going to wear she had drawn it up almost
like a a cartoon character it was
exactly what she had on uh during this
incident and she I was a previous
student she had some connections there
the head of the school was assassinated
in the hallway so we we feel it was
targeted and planned
she was targeting nine-year-old children
it's it's so unfortunate as this
investigation uh continues to go
um the kids were obviously targeted uh
praise goes out to the men and women who
the two officers actually who went into
the school because we could have had far
more casualties than what we had they
immediately uh responded went inside
addressed uh and mitigated the uh the
suspect and and I give the school credit
as well because for some reason the
alarm was going off the fire alarm and
there wasn't any kids in the hallway and
I think they've gone through some type
of training I'll find out more about
that today but they played a great role
as well in preventing more lives from
being lost
You Know Chief Drake you've spent a life
in law enforcement that involves seeing
some things I'm sure you've been in some
tough situations uh could you take us
back to the scene yesterday when you
arrived I heard you at the press
conference which I was covering live
yesterday uh talk about tears coming to
your eyes what did you see and how did
it move you
foreign
I was so hurt I've done this I've been
in this profession for 35 years and I've
trained for these type of situations
just as the officers have and when the
call went out I immediately canceled
everything I had going for the day went
out to the scene and it really was just
a few minutes from having to go into the
school myself I saw kids coming out
holding hand in hand I saw officers
coming out bleeding I saw uh just raw
emotion I had officers tell me they
wasn't sure if they could do this
anymore after carrying kids out of the
building uh it was just a it's a tough
uh tough scene what can you tell us
about the shooter have you talked to the
shooter's family what can you tell us
about this person
so we know the shooter to be Audrey Hale
28 years old she actually attended that
school
and has some history there we've talked
to the father and the mother they lived
on Brightwood Avenue we went to that
residence interviewed them searched a
home we found two more weapons there and
and I believe some more maps uh
pertaining to maybe some thinking about
some other incidents we strongly
believed there was going to be some
other targets including maybe family
members and one of the malls here in
Nashville
and it just did not happen
Chief your hometown is Nashville I would
like to give you an opportunity to send
a message to Nashville and the rest of
the country if you will because this is
something we are collectively dealing
with here in the U.S
I want to say to Nashville and to the
rest of the country we have to do
something with gun violence and mental
illness our kids are counting on this I
was in conversations with my daughter
this morning I have a four-year-old
grandson and she's considering
homeschooling a place where it's
supposed to be safe we send our little
loved ones off they're excited to go to
school they're excited to be around
friends and then have to deal with this
tragedy we have to come together we have
to address gun violence and we have to
address mental illness and make it safe
for the ones that we love the most and
our most vulnerable which of our kids
yeah we keep saying that message and
this keeps happening you said you talked
to Audrey Hill's parents what did they
say
so they it's really hard for them uh
emotionally right now our detectives
have talked to them and just combing
through trying to find out what was
going on it was just a really emotional
because they lost their child doing all
of this as well and so it's a very
traumatic for them too
wow Chief John Drake Thank you for
joining us